Donald Trump's signed off on moves to
tackle foreign interference in US
elections which he describes as a
national emergency the president's
issued an executive order which refers
to any attempt by individuals or
countries to influence or alter vote
results now the reason that he's so
concerned about all this is because a
lot rides on those crucial midterm
elections which are coming up in
November now in the event that any
meddling is Provins sanctions would be
imposed targeting strategic areas like
finance defense through to technology
and transport our Washington
correspondent Sameera Kahn's been taking
a closer look the order will authorize
sanctions against entities charged with
election meddling this applies to
accompanies organizations and even
individuals the term entity means a
partnership association trust joint
venture corporation group sub group or
other organizations now if impose these
sanctions will a block assets limit
access to the US financial system and
ban people from entering the country in
the order Trump admitted that no foreign
power has ever successfully influenced a
u.s. election but he signed the order
anyway although there has been no
evidence of a foreign power altering the
outcome or vote tabulation in any United
States election foreign powers have
historically sought to exploit America's
free and open political system now it's
also important to note that the order
did not specify any country in
particular the term foreign government
means any national state provincial or
other governing authority any political
party or any official of any governing
authority or political party in each
case of a country other than the United
States
these sanctions will also be imposed on
anyone accused of spreading propaganda
and disinformation and the authority
determined who's been meddling has been
granted to the Director of National
Intelligence the State Department the
Treasury Department Homeland Security
and the Justice Department with 45 days
to do so legal and media analyst Lionel
believes the executive orders vague
unlike previous documents of its kind
but a couple of things I want to bring
up using the canons of American law
which I know a little bit about
and whenever we look at any statute any
statute law regulation executive order
PDD you name it anything that is written
one of the tenets that we always look to
is are the behaviors are the prohibited
actions are those intended activities
spelled out accurately enough and with
specificity enough so that you are able
to read the particular executive order
read the statute and comport accordingly
meaning may I read this and say oh I
know what to do now the next thing is
sometimes we have terms void for
vagueness vagueness ambiguity what is
interference and I don't want to do this
the air quotes but imagine I'm doing it
what is interference what is propaganda
what is wanting to affect having an
effect and I can come up with a lot of
terms interpretations new ones if I
tweak the the Verity the veracity what
does this mean I don't even understand
how you would even apply this because
normally when you look at the statute it
says interference shall mean this it
means it does not mean this the
dissemination of an idea discussion
debate what does that what when any
country has any discussion I think there
is an effect so it's it's very concerned
it concerns me for vagueness and
ambiguity what it is is the US
presidency responding to the domestic
media and any doubts that people might
have of foreign interference in the
election the substance of it really is
not material because there are not going
to be any measurable indications of
foreign interference in the election
certainly not with those rigging or vote
amping in any event so so basically this
is a public relations exercise from the
White House
you